listen to the guide on the camera
I want you to get into octagon with him
in San Antonio
hey right here baby
so he's like whoa whoa right here baby
and then as soon as he gets up
and yeah I'd be terrified
face his exact words I'm gonna [__] your
face whoa dude chill man but I'm glad
that Rob did that yeah that's the thing
man it's like people don't realize like
these you realize that's a professional
cage fighter one of the best to ever do
it and you're literally three feet away
from talking yeah you know that's that's
like the perception with the great white
or the alligator and they're like what
it bit my arm it's like yeah dude yeah
yeah the [__] you up man and he acted
hard until morale started playing
further yeah but I'll climbed that thing
like goddamn spider monkey dude